今日は犯罪者ですなんか今回ですね柏さんかな
こちらの x リーグの良い fzr 8結構
提供させていただいたんですよこんな僕が提供何でも畏れ多いんですけど
どんな感じなの
デジカメですね
can you do
me
voodoo
このデジカメまずすごい
レスポンスがいいのとタイムラプスっていう機能はついてまして
大ペラーダ井村フィスっていうのはねうんなんだろ
ちょっと時間を上げてシャッターを下ろしてそれをつなげて動画みたいにでいう
よくあるのが雲の流れとか車の移動を取ったりそういうねちょっとありきたりの動画
ばっかりで僕はもう運縁しちゃってるんだよ
うーん
ええええええ
ん
で今回猫の zr
この ea 9 z 800を使って僕は
髪の毛見ての通り僕今髪の毛がもっさりなチーズの
ちょっと金髪っぽいんで品なのでイギリス行ったらいじめないんですよ
そんなのが嫌なんで
ちょっと美容室
人強化をとって
この鍵が去年真っ黒と短くツルンっていうのはこの
zr 800のタイムロッツ機能を使って
すごい流れるように多分間だけがも真っ黒の短くなると思うんでみてくださいよ
the 行ってきます
結構
わかりましたわかりましたもう言いたいかがわかります
タイムラプスの時間が短いってことで多いタイのとありだけ黒にし
してねえじゃねえかっていうのとまあ髪だけ短くなってるんじゃないかって3点を言い
たいなぁもうわかりましたありがとうます真っ黒になっちゃったんですけど
水がいいですよね
じゃあけどきっとこれぐらいの方がいいんですよだいぶラピス出版したのは
ん
sutter 下すタイミングを設定できてこの zr 800が設定ができるっけ
それねちょっと髪の毛切るの時間飾れなと思ったら結構10分ちょいぐらいで終わっ
ちゃって
ちょっとダサい目が開きすぎてすっごい短い動画にがございましたね
もうずシャッターを速めでまぁ綺麗に撮れたということで
ダイムラーして使う際はそれでも気をつけていただきたいと思います失格
タイムラプス機能があるんで
まあありきたりなんですけど雲の動きたのも見てください
どうぞ
分
goo
me